[음악]
안녕하세요 시드입니다 저는 글 쓰는
걸 좋아하고 말하는 걸 좋아하고
그리고 옷 좋아하는 패션회사 다니는
사람입니다 원래는 제가 블로그에서 몇
년간 패션 얘기를 했었는데 제가
말하는 거 좋아하는만큼 이걸 살려보면
좋지 않을까 생각해서 영상을 찍어
보게 됐습니다 시작으로 요즘 제가
자주 입는 스타일 하나를 공유해 보려
합니다 점점 겨울이 완연해지고 있는
요즘 저는 울자 캐에 자주 입는데요
자켓 중에서 제가 말하고 싶은 건 그
테일러링이 들어간 형태인데 좀 더
겨울 두께감이 옷들이 있잖아요 그런
것들입니다 제가이 우 자켓에 꽂히게
된 계기가 아직도 기억나는데 몇 년
전에 지하철역에서 그 고속 토미널
역이었다 있는데 앞에 있는 여자분
착장이 너무 예쁜 거예요 아마 르메르
보이는 회색 박시 자켓에 좀 큰
목도리를 칭칭 감아준 걸 보고 나도
저런 거 하나사 다
생각했습니다 제가 우 자켓을 몇 번
입어 보니까 일단 겨울철에 깔끔한
느낌 내기 좋으면서 나름 따뜻합니다
그리고 목도리랑 잘 어울려요 물론
나는 겨울에 패딩 밖에 안 입는데라고
하는 분들이 있다면 가을이나 초겨울에
입어 보시는 걸 추천합니다 아니면 그
코트나 파카리 안에 입으시는 것도
괜찮아요 저도 그렇게 많이 입습니다
아무튼 제가 가진 우 자켓 중에
아끼고 소개해드리고 싶은 제품 몇
개를 오늘 꺼내 볼까
합니다 처음 소개할 울자 켓은 매종
마르지엘라의 20fw 시즌 카라리스
자켓입니다 많은 분들이 마르지엘라의
카라리스 자켓 하면 아마 단추도 없고
정말 그 깔끔한 자켓을 기억하실
텐데요 물론 그 자켓도 제가 갖고
있고 정말 예쁘지만 저는 개인적으로
오늘 소개할이 제품이 좀 더 특별한
것 같습니다 마르젤라 시즌마다 캐리
오버로이 미니멀한 카라리스 자켓에
출시하다 제 기억으로는 20fw
시즌부터 이런 독특한 형태 제품이
나오기 시작했어요 저는 쇼를 보고 와
진짜 예쁘다고 생각하고 있는 와중에
정말 운좋게 매물로 택 달린 상품에
옷걸이까지 좋은 가격에
구했습니다이 제품은 매종 마르젤라
특유의 해체주의적 디테일이 굉장히
많은데요 어깨 봉제선도 그대로 있고요
소매 단추 달아야 하는 부분 표시되어
있는 봉제 있고요 그리고 밑단은 다
럭 커팅이 들어가서 실밥이 짜르르
달려 있습니다 또 본래 카라리스
자켓처럼 겹으로 되어 있는게 아니라
안감도 굉장히 신경 쓴 느낌이 들어서
매우 마음에
듭니다이 제품은 긴기장으로 해서
코트로도 나오는 걸로 알고 있어요
저는 주로 셔츠 위에다가 있기도
하지만 좀 더 추워지면 비슷한
색감이나 무채색의 터틀을 안에
입습니다이 제품이 무채색이고 미니멀해
보이는 구석도 있지만 실제로 입어
보면 생각보다 존재감이 있어서이 옷을
입을 때 다른 옷들은 좀 더 조용하게
가져가는
편입니다 두 번째 우유 자켓은
제이프레스 시오타의 협업으로 만들어진
2fw 시젠 제품입니다이 자켓은 제가
작년 12월 초쯤에 구매한 걸로
기억합니다 작년에 제가 꽂혀 있던
영화가 하나 있었는데 바로 레이니데이
뉴욕인데 솔직하게 영화는 그냥
그랬어요 그런데 거기서 티모씨 샬라메
님이 입고 나온 그 헤링본 패턴의 우
자켓이 너무 예쁜 거예요 제가
알기로는 라이프 로렌의 제품인데
찾아서 입어 보니까 저는 그 적당히
여유로운 핏이 안 나오는 거예요
그래서 좀 입고 살았어요 그러던
와중에 제가 자주 가는 한남동에 맥클
갔는데이 자켓이 있는 거예요 어
헤링본
패턴이네요 어 예쁘더라고요 그런데
셋업으로 바지도 있 거예요 바지도
입어 봐야겠다 하고 입었는데 얘도
핏이 너무 예쁘더라고요 제가 고민하고
있으니까 직원분이 두다 시즌 오프라고
알려주더라고요 그래서 바로 둘 다
결제했습니다이 자켓은 제가 구매한 우
자켓 중에 단연 제일 잘 입고
다녔어요 제이프레스 USA 클래식
모델을 기반해서
깔끔하면서도이 시터와 컬래버레이션을
하면서 출시된 제품이라 넉넉한
실루엣이 나와서 굉장히 편합니다
심지어 해외 여행 갈 때도 입었어요
제가이 제품은 원사가 굉장히 독특한데
우루가이 울과 수빈 코트는 엮어 만든
날씨를 포함해 여섯 종의 원사를
사용했다고 합니다 그렇게 해서
빈티지한 질감을 만들었는데 겉감을
만지면이 불규칙한 원단감이 느껴져서
클래식한 자켓인데 또 투박함
느껴져요이 제품은 여유롭게 나온
자켓이다 보니까 안쪽에 티셔츠 셔츠
스웨터나 후드티까지 잘 올 입니다
그렇지만 헤딩 본 패턴의 자켓만이
주는 그 지적인 매력이 확실히 있는
거 같아요 그래서 요새는 이런
샴브레이 셔츠나 비슷한 톤의 스웨터나
터틀 렉을 안에 주로 입습니다 그리고
안경도 자주 쓰고요 셋업 자체가
예뻐서 가치도 많이 입고 생지도 자주
입습니다 저는이 제품에 대한 만족도가
꽤 높아서 올해 초에 도쿄에 갔을
때도 제이프레스 매장에 갔었습니다
프레스의 단독 제품들도 예쁘고
오타와의 다른 협업 모델 그리고 다른
브랜드들과의 협업 제품들도 예쁘니까
관심 생기면 한번가 보시는 걸
추천드립니다 그다음은 리르의 이번
이사 FW 시즌 워커 자켓입니다
리르는 제가 요즘 가장 눈여겨 보고
있는 브랜드 중 하난데요 올해 1
2월쯤에 텐꼬르소 코모 매장에서
추천을 받고 처음 알게 됐습니다이
옷들의 재질이 독특하고 실루엣이
예뻐서 나중에 찾아보다가 이번 이사
시즌에 완전히 빠지게 됐어요 제가
구매한 자켓의 색상명은 캐슬 락이라고
되어 있어요 성벽의 색이라 부르는 거
같은데 제가 느꼈을 때는 안마른
시멘트 색깔이랑 비슷해요 저는 이런
스님들이 입으시는 그 승복 색감
있잖아요 그런 걸 좋아합니다 리에를
보면이 색감을 자주 쓰더라고요 좀
도시적이면서도 너무 차갑지만은 않은
그런
회색 제가 구매한이 워커 자켓은 매
시즌마다 리에서 출시하는 캐리오버
제품입니다 그런데 앞서 말씀드린
마르젤라 그래도 그랬듯이 매 시즌
나오지만 조금씩 다릅니다 제가 구매한
이번 시즌 제품은 그 히든 버튼
형태로 돼 있어요 그래서 단추를 모두
잠그면 보다 깔끔하게 연출할 수가
있습니다 그리고 이번 시즌엔 동일한
스타일이지만 크롭한 재켓 롱코트
그리고 제가 구매한 적당한 기장의
재켓 총 세 가지로 나왔습니다
가장 포인트가 되는 건 아무래도
카라일본 모르겠지만 아무튼 논
카라입니다 저는 이런 논카라 제품을
카라가 있는 인어를 안에 입고 카라만
빼서 입는 걸
선호하는데요 그래서 비슷한 색감의
오무 플릿의 셔츠와 입어봤는데
예쁘더라고요 그래도 브랜드에서 연출한
것처럼 본래 넥라인에 살리고 회색
톤온톤으로 입는게 가장 좋을 것
같습니다
네 번째는 르메르의 이번 이사 FW
시즌 쇼트 맥시 더블 코트입니다
르메르 제가 정말 애정하는 브랜드 중
하나고 가장 옷장의 지분을 많이
차지하고 있는 브랜드인데요 이번
제품은 사실 자켓은 아니고 코트입니다
몇 달 전에 한강진 있는 르메르
매장에 가서 이사 FW 신상들을 막
보고 있는데이 제품이 있는 거예요
더블 브레데 너무 날카로운 느낌이
들지도 않고 르에 부드러운 느낌이
나서 너무 마음에 들었습니다 거기다가
어느 바지에 잘 어울리는 짙은 회색이
좀 비슷한 색감을 찾아보자면 아이폰의
그 그래파이트 모델의
색깔입니다 그런데 고민하면서
찾아보니까 이게 자켓이 아니라
코트라고 르메르 자주 쓰는 방법인데
동일한 디자인의 제품을 짧은 버전
하나 그리고 긴버전 하나 이런 식으로
두 개를냅니다 이번 시즌만 봐도 더플
코트가 장에 따라 두 가지로 나왔어요
마찬가지로이 제품도 더블 브레스티드
울코트 두 가지 버전 중 짧은
버전입니다 그래서인지 코트라서 좀
기장이 길어요 제 엉덩이를 다
가립니다 잠깐 르메르 사이즈에 얘기를
하자면 르메르 꼭 입어보고 사시는 걸
추천합니다 어떤 옷은 작게 나와서
공이나 엑스라지 입어야 하고 또 어떤
건 엄청 오버하게 나와서 작은
사이즈를 입어야 하는데요 이 제품은
완벽하게 후자에 속합니다 제가이 옷을
무려 스몰 사이즈를 입어요 제가 입는
르메르 옷 중에서는 사이즈
표기상으로는 제일 작아요 그런데도
오버입니다이 제품은 목도리도 해보고
가방도
둘러봤습니다 목도리는 제 목돌이
상자에서 일단 비슷한 색감으로 빠르게
골라봤는데 아까 말했던 그 승복
색감입니다
자켓에 목도리를 두르면 이런
느낌이라는 걸 보여 드리려고 하는 거
까 참고만 해 주시면
감사하겠습니다 가방은 르메르 크루아상
백을 같이
둘러줬어요이 제품은 오늘 말씀드리는
울자켓 중에는 가장 두께감이 얇아요
그래서 사실 가을에 단품 연출을
하거나 겨울철에는 중간 아우터로
입는게 좋을 것
같습니다 마지막으로 소개할 제품은
샌드 사운드의
자켓입니다이 자켓은 오늘 소개하는
아이템 중에 가장 합리적인 가격을
자랑하는 제품인데요 그런데 퀄리티도
꽤나 괜찮아요이 제품이 제일 마음에
들었던 건 제가 아까 말한 예전에 그
지하철에서 보고 처음 떠올렸던 우
자켓의 이상적인 느낌이 나오기
때문입니다이 자켓은 두께감이 눈으로
보나 입어 보나 굉장히 두툼해요 엄청
그 단단한 울소재로 되어 있다 보니까
꽤나 본성도 좋고 목도리 와도 잘
어울립니다 그리고이 제품은 어깨
라인도 그렇고 굉장히 오버데어 그
옛날에 나왔던 라프시몬스 자켓의 박시
비슷한 느낌의 연출이
나옵니다이 우 자켓을 좀 단정하게
입어봤는데 사실 넉넉한 실루엣의
트레이닝 팬츠와도 잘 어울리더라고요
그 트레이닝 펜츠 아니 그 똑같은
말이지만 진짜 그 추리닝 같은
거에다가 보이캡 푹 눌러쓰고 목돌이
칭칭 둘러주고 컨버스 구겨신고 후드티
위에다가 이런 울자켓 하나 딱
입어주면 편하면서도 좀 멋있는 코디가
될 것
같습니다 영상을 준비하는 사이에
날씨가 더 많이 추워졌는데요 다음에는
좀 더 계절감에 맞는 보따리를
풀어보겠습니다 제가 오늘 준비한
이야기는 여기까지입니다 감사합니다